je me prépare simplement d'accord
journée initiation ce dimanche 9 juillet
au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines une
quarantaine de riders de la petite
course une compétition à pignon fixe
organisée la veille à paris sont venus
tester les boss du stadium de bmx
tout cela sous l'oeil vigilant d'un
coach diplômé d'état moi je mise
beaucoup sur l'équilibré les exercices
sans pédales et après on regarde un
petit peu haut niveau conduite comment
comment les pratiques en arrive à
pédaler parce qu'on est sur une
discipline où il faut pédaler tout le
temps de goût donc ça peut poser
quelques problèmes pour certains c'est
pas un sport de cascadeur il faut quand
même être mesuré et contrôlé ce qu'on
fait donc faut gérer sa vitesse
après une vingtaine de minutes dès ses
premières réactions
en fait j'avais un peu peur au début je
pense et du coup ça me bloquer un peu et
au final quand on voit les autres le
faire on dit qu'on va pas y arriver il
faut essayer une fois et après ça va une
fois la première initiation terminé
place à la piste les riders venus des
quatre coins de la france ont pu
découvrir l'antre du vélodrome nationale
habitué à pratiquer le vélo à pignon
fixe sans frein ces têtes brûlées n'ont
pas eu de mal à dompter les virages à 43
degrés même si j'avais pas fait de piste
avant c'est quand même plus simple après
on a quand même appréhension parce qu'on
arrive sur un mur qui est presque droit
et on se demande comment on va réussir à
tenir dessus mais c'est très bien aller
je suis super contente ça donne vraiment
envie d'en faire après on est vraiment
dans un superbe au vélodrome donc ça
encourage encore plus depuis son
lancement en 2015 le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines a effectué
plus de 10000 baptême sur piste dans la
structure